about me
this is about you the readers
protecting reporters sources tonight at
8 pm eastern on c-span
the warren commission released its
report on the kennedy assassination 40
years ago in september the assassination
archives and research center hosted a
symposium on the commission's findings
next is david talbot editor of salon.com
he spoke about the response to the
warren report at the time of its release
this is about an hour
our first speaker this afternoon is
david talbot
of salon.com
who is going to speak to us about what
the high and the mighty thought
about the kennedy assassination
thanks jim and
thank you to all the organizers of this
conference um as a
as a uh
as a relative newcomer to this uh
fascinating world
i've been learning a lot
i can't pass myself off as an expert as
uh
all the other speakers have been
you won't hear anything from me about
mock banding or bullet lead analysis
maybe that's a relief
but
i am working on a book that i think has
relevance to
uh some of the work that's being done
and i'd love to hear from all of you
i'm going to be giving a talk that's
based on an article that i recently
wrote and published in salon some of you
might have seen it but i'll be going off
script a number of times if you have
read it and
asking i would like to have a dialogue
with some of you about this
i'm fascinated by this question of
course
about what
the
people in government uh the political
elite themselves thought about the crime
of the century
uh
i think it's uh the conference is well
timed of course because once again we
find ourselves in the season of the
official report the 911 commission
report the senate select committee on
intelligence report
the schlesinger inquiry on abu ghraib
among others
and once again the official version is
under fire the 911 report of course has
been attacked for leaning over backwards
in the spirit of bipartisan unanimity to
avoid pinning blame on the bush
administration for its casual attitude
towards terrorist alerts
before the calamity and for sidestepping
the issue of saudi involvement but at
least it's one a measure of public
respect due in large part to the
vigilance of 9 11 victims families and
when it comes to government inquiries i
think this is the key
the extent to which the public is
involved
the senate report on the intelligence
failures leading to the iraq war has not
fared as well of course undoubtedly
because it lacked the same public
oversight
this report went to even greater
extremes to keep bush out of the
crosshairs as thomas powers recently
wrote in the new york review of books no
tyrannical father presiding over an un
presiding over an intimidated household
was ever tiptoed around with greater
caution than as the figure of president
george w bush in the committee's fat
report
and this lessens your report on auburn
graves quickly earned itself an utterly
contemptuous response eliciting
widespread outrage for giving defense
secretary rumsfeld and the pentagon a
sweeping pass on the reign of torture at
the prison
so it is only appropriate in this stormy
season
of the official version and its
discontents that we observed the 40th
anniversary of the warren report
the mother of all such controversies
the vast 26 volume report was of course
delivered to chief justice earl warren
by chief justice earl warren to
president johnson on september twenty
fourth nineteen sixty four
and as we know the warren report
concluded that president kennedy was the
victim of a lone unstable assassin
lee harvey oswald
who was of course conveniently
uh gunned down two days later by
jack ruby
the warren commission
itself the victim of massive fraud and
manipulation by the fbi and cia
came under immediate fire from critics
with its report being denounced as a
government cover-up by a growing army of
independent researchers some of of
course are with us at the conference
history has not been any kinder to the
warren report which has been derided
and condemned by everyone from the house
select committee on assassinations the
only other federal panel to exhaustively
probe kennedy's murder and which found
in 1979 that the president was the
probable target of a conspiracy
to oliver stone in his explosive 1991
film
jfk to the history channel which
routinely airs the even the outer limits
of conspiracy theories
four decades later the warren report is
widely regarded as whitewash with polls
consistently showing the majority of
americans reject the official version of
kennedy's death
but there is one sanctuary where the
warren report is still stubbornly upheld
and where its manifold critics can
expect their own rough treatment
and that's in the towers of the media
elite my profession
fresh from assaulting oliver stone not
only for his film but his very character
and let me step aside to say this is an
assault that i have engaged in the past
also attacking the film jfk and i know
david rohn yesterday said that he
found i think 90
was a david of the film
to be an error
uh
whatever
its merits as a historical document of
course it can't be reviewed as a
documentary
i do think now looking back uh over a
dozen years later
that the film has had
i would say a positive impact in the
american debate it of course resulted in
the release of thousands of documents
that many of you are being are using for
your own research
and i find that there was an emotional
truth in that film
not unlike perhaps uh don
delillo's excellent novel libra and
james elroy's novel american tabloid so
it's my feeling that oliver stone has to
be read as he is as a fiction filmmaker
but i certainly think he opened the
debate in a useful way
in any case
uh the media elite of course uh
we're all over oliver stone
uh and shortly thereafter rush to
embrace gerald posner's book case closed
in 1993 making that book a bestseller
the most convincing explanation of the
assassination historian robert dallach
called it in the boston globe
and the 40th anniversary of the
assassination in dallas last november of
course sparked a new canon aid of
anti-conspiracy sound and fury in the
media
with abc's peter jennings leading the
way this time making yet another network
news attempt to silence the report's
critics
now most of the press lords and pundits
of course from the 1960s who allowed
themselves to be convinced that the
warren report was the correct version of
what happened in dallas whether because
they genuinely believed it
or because they thought it was for the
good of the country
are now dead or retired
but after buying the official version
for so long it seems that the elite
media
have too much invested in the warren
report to change their minds now
even if they're under new editorial
leadership
i'll be interested to see how much
coverage the warren reports anniversary
for instance does get uh in the coming
week
one of the great ironies of history
however is that while the media elite
was busily trying to shore up public
confidence in the war and report the
country's political elite was privately
confiding among themselves that the
report was a travesty
a fairy tale for mass consumption
presidents white house aides
intelligence officials
senators congressmen
even foreign leaders they all muttered
darkly among themselves
that kennedy was killed by a conspiracy
a plot that a number of them suspected
had roots in the u.s government itself
now to be fair some high media
dignitaries themselves also quietly
shared their doubts about the official
version
in 1993 cbs
anchorman who's in trouble again dan
rather
uh
reportedly confided
to robert tannenbaum the former deputy
chief counsel of the house select
committee on assassinations quote we
really blew it on the kennedy
assassination
thanks to tapes of white house
conversations that have been released to
the public in rel in recent years we now
know that the man who appointed the
warren commission president lyndon
johnson did not believe its conclusions
on september 18th as we've heard at the
conference
1964
the last day the panel met commission
member senator richard russell phoned
johnson his old political protege to
tell him he did not believe the single
bullet theory the key to the
commission's finding that oswald acted
alone i don't either johnson told him
i'll defer to max holland who of course
is with us
as the expert on these tapes and lbj's
of course uh opinions about private
opinions about what happened in dallas
and i'm halfway through max's book and
as i've told them i find it very useful
and again i want to say that i know
there's uh differences of opinion here
and i've uh already complimented jim
lazar on uh in the spirit of i think
open inquiry inviting people
with different opinions about what
happened in dallas to be here today
and this weekend
uh
in any case we do we do know that lbj
had uh
differing views than that of the warren
commission on the assassination
uh he seemed to fix uh on castro and
cuba as the source of the plot
he uh
weighed heavily on him throughout his uh
his term in office
and max uh i just had lunch with max and
i pointed out how intriguing this
particular uh statement uh in his book
was he ends his introduction
max does in his new book saying
that it's virtually an article of faith
among historians that the war in vietnam
was the overwhelming reason the
president left office in 1969 a war and
and disillusioned man yet the
assassination related tapes paint a more
nuanced portrait one in which johnson's
view of the assassination
weighing as heavily on him as did the
war
now critics of the warren report were
often uh of the critics of the warren
report
loan assassination conclusion were often
stumped by defenders of the report
with a question if there was a
conspiracy
why didn't president kennedy's own
brother bobby the attorney general of
the united states do anything about it
and all of us who know uh
american presidential history know that
there was probably never another uh
brother act in american politics or
government like the kennedy brothers
that they were uniquely close
that bobby was the tough aggressive
protector of the kennedy family and of
his brother in particular
and that if anyone would have done
anything to get to the bottom of what
happened to his brother in dallas it
would have been bobby kennedy so why
didn't he at least publicly
do something about it
and it is true that at least until
shortly before his own death in june
1968 bobby kennedy publicly supported
the warren report
on march 25th during a presidential
campaign rally at san fernando valley
state college
in california now called cal state
northridge kennedy was dramatically
confronted by a woman heckler who called
out we want to know who killed president
kennedy
kennedy responded by saying
i stand by the warren commission report
i think he says it's an interesting tape
if you listen to it and then he says
everything will come out in the end
i've seen what's in the archives
everything will come out
but in a later campaign appearance days
before his assassination
according to his former press spokesman
frank mankowitz who i've interviewed
several times
bobby kennedy said the opposite
when asked if he would reopen the
investigation into his brother's death
he uttered a simple one-word answer yes
mankowitz recalls today quote i remember
that i was stunned by the answer
it was either like he was suddenly
blurting out the truth or or or it was a
way to shut down the question you know
yes now let's move on
bobby's political public statements on
the warren report were obviously
freighted with political and emotional
and perhaps even security concerns for
him for himself
but we have no doubt what his private
opinion of the report was as his
biographer evan thomas wrote kennedy
regarded the warren commission as a
public relations exercise
to reassure the public
end quote
according to a variety of reports
kennedy immediately suspected the plot
as soon as he heard his brother had been
shot in dallas
and as he made calls and inquiries in
the hours and days after the
assassination he came to an ominous
conclusion his brother was the victim of
a domestic political conspiracy
in a remarkable passage that i'm sure a
number of you are familiar with but not
the public at large unfortunately
in the book one hell of a gamble the
widely praised 1997 history of the cuban
missile crisis based on declassified
soviet and u.s government documents
historians alexander forsenko and
timothy naftali wrote that on november
29th one week after the assassination
bobby dispatched a close family friend
named william walton to moscow with a
remarkable message for georgie bolshakov
the kgb agent who bobby had come to
trust during the nerve-wracking back
channel negotiations
during the missile crisis
according to these historians walton
told bolshikov that bobby and jacqueline
kennedy believed quote there was a large
political conspiracy behind oswald's
rifle and quote that dallas was the
ideal location for such a crime
the kennedys also sought to reassure the
soviets that despite oswald's apparent
connections to the communist world they
believed president kennedy had been
killed by american enemies
this is a stunning account of course
with the fallen president's brother and
widow communicating their chilling
suspicions privately to the preeminent
world rival of the u.s
and it does not receive nearly the
public attention or scholarly inquiry it
deserves
both khrushchev who had been working
with jfk to ease tensions between the
superpowers and his spy chief shared
kennedy's dark view of the assassination
kgb chairman vladimir sumit chastny
reacted incredulously to the news that
oswald a man whom his agency had closely
monitored
during oswald's stay in the soviet union
was the culprit
i thought this man could not possibly be
the mastermind of the crime okay the kgb
chairman was quoted as saying and
according to prasenko and naftali
intelligence coming to khrushchev in the
weeks following the assassination seemed
to confirm the theory
that a right-wing conspiracy had killed
kennedy an assessment that was shared by
the governments of cuba mexico and
france
where president de gaulle when briefed
by a reporter on the lone nut theory
reacted with gallic skepticism laughing
you're kidding me cowboys and indians
in the years after his brother's death
bobby kennedy was overwhelmed by a grief
that was beyond grief
but the common perception that he found
it too painful to focus on the
assassination
is simply not the case
my own research has shown that during
the years between his brother's death
and his own death he dispatched a number
of surrogates including mankowitz his
press his press spokesman walter
sheridan
his trusted investigator who worked with
him on the jimmy hoff investigation ed
guthman
who had been his spokesman at the
justice department and later became
editor of the new york times and john
siegenthaler another journalist who had
worked with him closely over the years
to check out their work the work of
assassination critics
uh
jim garrison among others
in fact kennedy himself phoned new
orleans coroner nicholas chetta at his
home after the death of key garrison
suspect david ferry to question chetta
about his autopsy report on ferry
and while sheridan a trusted friend of
kennedy's who had worked closely with
him as i said on the hoff investigate
a former fbi agent who worked as a
garrison investigator
during on the kennedy case in april 1968
garrison's office that is turner
received a call in new orleans
from an rfk campaign aide named richard
lubick he said bill bobby's going to go
he's going to reopen the investigation
after he wins i went in immediately and
told garrison he didn't seem surprised
now psy hirsch among others who i of
course have great respect for
uh in his book which takes a very dark
view of course of the kennedy dynasty
the dark side of camelot
uh it says emphatically that bobby never
would have opened
the assassination if he had lived and
been elected president because of the
skeletons that he was afraid would have
come tumbling out the cia the mafia the
women etc
but it's my feeling from the research
i've done that i think bobby was
grappling
towards
a strategy
a strategy that he would put in that he
would implement once he was elected
president and that the closer he
actually got to the white house and he
thought it was more likely he would have
the power
to reopen the inquiry i think it became
more and more of an issue for him
emotionally and politically
but i'm convinced he was headed in that
direction
bobby of course was not the only member
of president kennedy's inner circle who
believed there was a conspiracy
presidential aides kenny o'donnell and
dave powers who were members of jfk's
irish mafia
were in a trailing limousine in the
dallas motorcade both of them later told
house speaker tip o'neill that they
heard two shots from behind the fence on
the grassy knoll
that's not what you told the warren
commission a stunned o'neill replied
according to his 1989 memoir man of the
house you're right said o'donnell i told
the fbi what i had heard but they said
it couldn't have happened that way and
that i must have been imagining things
so not wanting to quote stir up more
pain and trouble for the family
o'donnell told the commission what the
fbi wanted him to
blunt skepticism about the warren report
was a bipartisan affair with leaders on
both sides of the aisle aerially
dismissing its conclusions
uh we know that president nixon was a
skeptic one of his
top aides white house chief of staff h.r
bob haldeman
shared his boss of skepticism in his own
1978 memoir the ends of power
haldeman
wrote that he'd always been intrigued
with the conflicting theories about the
assassination
and recalls that when the white house
when the nixon team finally moved into
the white house
he felt that they quote would now be in
a position to get all the facts end
quote
but nixon perhaps wary of
wary of where all those facts would lead
rejected haldeman's suggestion
according to haldeman nixon did play the
assassination card in a mysterious way
however against cia director richard
helms
long regarded by some warren reports
warn report critics to have knowledge
about the gunshots
in dallas
seeking to pressure the cia into helping
him out of his watergate mess nixon head
holdem and deliver this cryptic message
apparently a threat of some sort to
helms
quote the president asked me to tell you
this entire watergate affair may be
connected to the bay of pigs
and if it opens up the bay of pigs may
be blown this is what hauled him and
told helms in a meeting
this prompted an explosive reaction from
the cia spymaster turmoil in the room
haldeman writes in his book helms
gripping the arms of his chair leaning
forward and shouting the bay of pigs had
nothing to do with this i have no
concern about the bear pigs
haldeman speculates that the bay of pigs
must have been nixon's code for
something related to the cia castro and
the kennedy assassination
but whatever dark card nixon had played
it worked according to haldeman he
reported back to his boss that the cia
director was now suddenly very happy to
be helpful
nixon was not willing to publicly reopen
the box of assassination demons but many
of them began flying out when the church
committee began investigating cia abuses
in the 1970s including the unholy pact
between the agency and the mafia to
eliminate fidel castro
among those in washington who were
particularly curious about the
revelations that were come coming out
about the cia
and the kennedy assassination was george
bush
george bush senior
as kitty kelly observes in her new book
about the bush family while serving as
the cia director in the ford
administration bush fired off a series
of memos
in fall 1978 asking subordinates in the
agency various questions about oswald
ruby helms and other figures tied to the
assassination
quoting uh from kitty's new book years
later when bush became president of the
united states he would deny making any
attempt to review the agency files on
the jfk assassination
when he made this claim he did not
realize that the agency would release 18
documents under the freedom of
information act that showed he had
indeed as cia director
requested information not once but
several times on a wide range of
questions surrounding the kennedy
assassination
one of the most aggressive investigators
on the church committee was the young
ambitious democratic senator from
colorado gary hart who along with the
republic his uh republican colleague
richard schweiker of pennsylvania
began digging into the swampy murk of
southern florida in the early 1960s
here of course was the steamy nursery
for plots that drew together cia
saboteurs mafia assassins anti-communist
cuban fanatics and the whole array of
patriotic zealots who were determined to
overthrow the cuban government
the iraq of its day
gary hartner interview with me said the
whole atmosphere down there in florida
at the time was so yeasty i don't think
anybody helms or anybody had it had
control of the thing
there were people clandestinely meeting
people the mafia connections the
friendships between the mafia and the
cia agents and this crazy cuban exile
community
there were more and more layers and it
was honeycombed with bizarre people i
don't think anybody knew everything that
was going on and i think the kennedys
were kind of racing to keep up with it
all
end quote from gary hart
schweiker's mind was blown by what he
and hart were digging up there's no
other way to describe it
here was a moderate republican from
pennsylvania and he would be later
chosen of course as vice presidential
running mate briefly by ronald reagan in
1976 to bolster his challenge against
president ford
but schweiker's faith in the american
government seemed deeply shaken by his
kennedy probe
which convinced him quote the
fingerprints of intelligence were all
over lee harvey oswald
gary hart told me quote dick made a lot
of statements inside the committee at
the time that were a lot more
inflammatory than anything i ever said
in terms of his suspicions about who
killed kennedy
he would say this is outrageous we've
got to open this up we've got to reopen
it he was a blowtorch
heart 2 concluded that kennedy was
likely killed by a conspiracy involving
some feverish cabal from the swamps of
anti-castro zealotry
and when he ran for president in 1984
hart says whenever he was asked about
the assassination quote my consistent
response was based on my church
committee experience there are
sufficient doubts about the case to
justify reopening the files of the cia
particularly in its relationship to the
mafia end quote
this was enough to blow other people's
minds his heart including remnants of
the mafia family florida godfather
santoro traffic county who plays a key
role in many jfk conspiracy theories
what gary hart then told me was
journalist hirsch told me that he
interviewed buddies of trafficante
including his right-hand man who was
still alive when hirsch wrote his book
the dark side of camelot
he didn't put this in his book but when
my name came up gary hart's name the guy
laughed he snored and said we don't
think he's any better than the kennedys
end quote from gary hart i asked senator
hart you meant that they were keeping an
eye on you as well
at the very least said gary hart this
was in the 1980s when i was running for
president saying i would reopen the
kennedy investigation anybody can draw
their own conclusions end quote
hart of course never made it to the
white house but another politician who
had been deeply inspired by jfk william
jefferson clinton did
and like perhaps every other man who'd
seemingly who moved has moved into the
white house following the kennedy
assassination he too was curious about
finding out the real story of dallas
where are the kennedy files
the young president reportedly asked
soon after he went to work in the oval
office
and what about that other jfk from
massachusetts who also met president
kennedy as a young man john f kerry if
he's elected in november
will he be tempted to launch an inquiry
and try to find out what really happened
to his hero in dallas
hart says he doubts it
you almost had to go through it like i
did with the church committee he told me
and get all the context otherwise you
have to be very careful about falling
into the conspiracy category i at least
had some credentials to talk about it
but if kerry were to bring it up people
would just say he's wacky he's obsessive
as as hart observes
there are other ways to kill a leader
these days you can assassinate his
character
and so 40 years after the warren report
with the country's political elite still
racked with suspicions about the kennedy
assassination and yet immobilized from
doing anything about it by fears of
being politically marginalized
and with the media elite continuing to
disdain even the most serious
journalistic inquiry the crime seems
frozen in place
it is now up to historians and scholars
and authors to keep the spirit of
inquiry alive
for decades the only public critics of
the warren report
was a heroic and indomitable band of
citizen investigators
including a crusading new york attorney
a small town texas newspaper man
a retired washington civil servant a
berkeley literature professor a los
angeles sign salesman the pittsburgh
coroner
all of whom refused to accept the fraud
that was perpetrated on the american
people
undaunted by the media scoring that was
heaped on them
they devoted their lives to what
government powerful government officials
and high paid media mandarins should
have been doing
solving the most shocking crime
against american democracy in the 20th
century
their names mark lane ray marcus harold
weisberg sylvia maher vincent salandria
mary farrell penn jones jr cyril wecht
josiah tink thompson peter dale scott
david rohn jim lazar gayton fonzie among
others
these names will find their honored
place in american history
it's these everyday heroes and their
successors many of whom are here today
as well
whose best work
will someday come to replace the heavy
and i feel counterfeit tomes of the
warren report
thank you
[Applause]
i'll take some questions but as they say
i can't get into the physical evidence
tink
if i could
i'd like to offer you some information
sure
with regard to the
media in the years shortly after the
assassination
um
i was hired by life magazine in the fall
of 1966
[Applause]
i think this genuinely had some
relevance and i
we would have talked privately about
this later but why not share it with you
with everyone else
um
i was hired by life in october of
1966
and together with uh dick billings and
ed kern
two very excellent editors of life
we ran an investigation
which ended up with the first major
break
in the
hegemony of
warren commission
apologies
that was an issue of life
which put on the cover grounds for
reasonable doubt
and it was the first fisher in the i
think andy has copies of that i bought
one yesterday is that right well it was
the first fisher in the media's sort of
total acceptance of the warren report
now
during that investigation i was hired
simply for time reasons they could have
trained up billings or current or anyone
in four months time
to get where i was they didn't have the
time
so they permitted me to tell them where
the bodies were buried to identify the
witnesses the places the issues the
questions
and i got to say i had absolutely total
support there were no questions about
should we interview x or y or anything
like that there was no control on this
investigation
whatsoever it went wherever it wanted to
go
and it went as far as we could go
it was unlimited
now i also have to say that the article
that was published
was clearly much blander
much thinner
than the than the information that we
had
now
uh various people will tell you that
life magazine isn't
is an organism of the elite and etc it
had to be controlled from above and
that's why the article
did not
include everything we had
that's nonsense
there was no control from above george
hunt the editor of life supported this
completely we had journalists who were
completely committed to it and were
running it
as hard as we could
well why did that happen well it
happened due to a kind of i think
institutional defect at life
life suffered from what might be called
committee journalism at that time
in terms of any major story any major
story published by life would have had
to be signed off on by at least 10
different people
the result of that institutional defect
was that any story on any issue
would be somewhat watered down this had
nothing to do with the kennedy
assassination it had to do with the way
life did did business at that time and i
suspect that something like that
was endemic in all the media in other
words too many people had to sign off on
something in order
for
anything to be really really hard edged
etc etc
now what happened
that issue came out in i think
late november
1966.
during the next month or so the
investigation sort of trailed off into
nowhere
why was that was it because the
investigation was controlled from above
no
the reason the investigation ended at
life and by the way we knew when we were
working at life that the new york times
had 12
a 12-man investigation under harris and
salisbury right in the field right and
we never met them we never knew what
they were doing but we knew they were
digging right
i think that investigation trailed off
for two significant reasons
one was that in january of 1967
through the grapevine of these critics
that you mentioned david i learned of
the
of the garrison investigation i told
dick billings about that garrison
investigation he flew to new orleans and
basically signed up garrison to an
exclusive contract with life
for the coverage of this investigation
so i think at that point by january a
billing certainly felt hey
something really big is going on here
we've got it i've signed it up
so
let's just follow that
there's another significant reason
though and
before we start kicking the media
i think we got to recognize this
we couldn't take it all the way at that
point right
we couldn't solve the crime
so at a certain point
in these matters in the kennedy
assassination you end up with this level
with this strata of ambiguity
which does not permit you if you're
a media editor
to mount a big terrific breakthrough
story in other words
we couldn't break it
and that really is this
is the simple answer now now many people
have
accused me of being a cia agent because
i worked for for time life is it true
for a few months you can deny it right
now yeah i'll deny it okay
um
and have claimed that life magazine
through
very complicated uh
uh relationships
was a uh basically a cia front
um disagree this of course is absolute
nonsense i mean
any journalist at that time in 1966
would have given their left arm to break
through on this case and everybody at
life we had the same notion we had the
thought that maybe if we got lucky and
if we looked in the right place and if
we pulled the right thread that we
really could could break it
and i think that's
that's the case throughout let me
mention only one other thing
um cbs
cbs has put together a series of
documentaries on this case beginning
very early i know there was one in 1967
that i want to particularly mention
mentioned
these were basically
apologies for for the warren commission
report
even there you find
the journalists who were actually
working on the stories right
were enthusiastic wanted to break
through etc etc but bob richter for
example leaked to me the the actual raw
data on the firing test which showed
just the opposite from what cbs finally
broadcast
so
i think if one's going to deal with the
media one has to recognize that the
working journalists who who do the
day-to-day work within these
institutions
are
are as committed
have been as committed to a breakthrough
in this case as as anyone
and
i still don't believe that any of these
journalists are controlled from above in
some sort of major conspiracy the basic
problem these journalists committed
journalists as they are have had from
the very beginning is
that they couldn't bring about a
breakthrough that this case is really
recalcitrant the evidence in this case
and that's why we're sitting here today
the evidence in this case remains
fundamentally recalcitrant to any single
interpretation so i just wanted to okay
thanks ting
yeah let me uh without getting too i
know we're gonna have a discussion of
media tomorrow which should cover some
of this grant so i won't go
uh too farther into i i take your point
tink i'm a little uh
though
you know uh skeptical about
the decisions having been in the media
all of my life now worked for various
organizations
where are those decisions made if the
working journalists want to keep pushing
where are the certain decisions made at
what level to cut off that process and
speaking of the new york times
investigation there was a great story
done that ray marcus just sent me
actually in rolling stone in the 1970s i
believe mid 70s
about the media coverage of the
assassination and went into that new
york times team investigation led by
managing editor at harrison salisbury
and they quoted uh
two or three of the reporters around
that team and at least one of them said
we were getting good stuff
and then somehow the plug got pulled and
they didn't know why or where but you
know he felt at least this one reporter
as i recall
uh you know beat reporter for the new
york times that they were coming up with
good stuff and somehow the the plug got
pulled anyway uh yes over here
when you look at a question like the
lead opinion
you ought to look in both directions to
see if elite supported the warren
commission
did you find elite support for the
warren commission
and did you find a pattern in who was
likely to support it and who is likely
to criticize it is there is there an
ideological
bias at work
here uh as i said i found bipartisan
skepticism uh on both sides of the aisle
uh i think people
among the critics in the elite of the
warren report i think the ideology comes
to where they think the conspiracy lay
do you think it was castro do you think
it was the anti-castro cubans and the
cia i think that's where the ideological
divide that i most often see yes of
course there were a number of people who
have continued to support the warren
report at least publicly but i don't
know what their private feelings were
these are the people i mentioned today
were the ones that i know who have been
documented as privately expressing their
skepticism you probably someone else
might be able to say here people who
firmly believed in the war and report
inside government who had some
inside knowledge about the war and
report but i i can't tell you right now
uh the woman right
here want to say that i i've been to
many of the conferences in dallas i'm a
native of dallas i saw the motorcade not
the assassination but the motorcade on
the 22nd
and have followed this avidly for
the past at least decade
and uh one person that definitely
deserves to be
noted among the critics is john judge
who has convened the meetings year after
year in dallas
where the people who have come to those
many in this room
i feel
they have solved the assassination it's
like a huge jigsaw puzzle people have
been bringing their pieces
to the table
and putting them on there they've been
finding the pieces of the puzzle lost
under the floorboards and bringing them
forward
and i think it's been solved and it's
very complex you have to read and dig
and listen to the witnesses
many as we all know have been scores of
people have been killed witnesses early
on
so i just do want to add john
judge's name to your list and
and ask that that work be acknowledged
that teamwork
thank you and i i knew when i made that
list again i'm a newcomer to the whole
research area here on this subject and i
knew i was going to leave some people
off and my apologies to anyone i did who
uh uh has been doing important work in
this field
yes over here
i don't have it with me but gary hart
also had a long paragraph in a book i
think called the right stuff
that he wrote
that indicated strongly that he believed
there was a
larger force
operating behind the conspiracy it
didn't say it in so many words but it
set it in between the lines
and i'm wondering about what you were
reading between the lines in your
recent was it interview with him yes it
was uh
was he telling you or did he
seem to be wanting to tell you that
maybe the donna rice incident had
something to do with his
he that was an anonymous phone call it's
a good question it's a good question i
mean clearly he was saying that uh as he
told me
that
you can stop a political figure who's
troublesome nowadays without a bullet
and uh
i can't comment on the donna rice uh
you know uh scandal
that clearly did end his uh presidential
hopes uh
he
i just can't go there
but it's a good question
what he had said to you that it was
going toward that
i just can't comment on that he did tell
me some things and and he asked for some
things to be off the record but i quoted
him here was uh what he wanted to be
quoted on the record saying
yes right here
can you hear me yeah i really enjoy your
presentation thanks for coming um you
brought up um president clinton's um
intrigue in the case i just want to know
since his eight years in office what
were his contributions and
accomplishments of anything
of bringing out the case that's a very
good question i knew i would uh be asked
that uh all i know about clinton and his
uh you know suspicions or curiosity
maybe it's just uh you know simple
curiosity about the assassination i just
reported to you uh it came from a
clinton aide i can't tell you who it is
again it was off the record but i found
it intriguing that was one of the first
things that bill clinton was curious
about uh yeah you might have just added
that i think if you check
the
deputy attorney general hubble
uh in his book indicates that when
uh he was appointed to his position that
clinton asked him to find out about two
things one of which was the kennedy
assassination and the other was flying
saucers
and uh they had a huge tussle
and uh clinton rather than standing with
the fbi forced him into negotiations and
ultimately gently nudged the fbi to
release documents
particularly because the fbi kept saying
that by releasing this information it
would come from my sources and methods
the review board found a new york times
article that in fact the fbi's own study
showed that it didn't compromise
sources and methods to do the kind of
releasing they were doing and ultimately
the decision was for disclosure so
clinton was i think at least helpful in
that way
thank you yes
right here
yes i have a comment and a footnote uh
politicians as you illustrated are
suspicious by nature
on the other hand to be fair
because i say this with respect to all
politicians good or bad it's
inconceivable that a working politician
could devote the kind of concentration
that is necessary to make sense out of
this case
it just couldn't happen it's a very
complex case and and but he could
delegate others he could yes
and i think that's true and i think
there's no reason why we should uh
assume that the political leader any
more knowledgeable than people in this
room and i think max holland who i had
lunch with before i don't know if max is
here but he would say the same thing i
mean of course he's been immersed in the
documents on lbj for his book and i
think i don't want to speak for max but
i think he would say hey
there's no reason why we should put any
more uh
credence in what lbj had to say about
the assassination than any of us
but
it's interesting isn't it i mean you do
want to know what your leaders are
talking about privately about this uh if
i may one other footnote about george
h.w bush he had another reason to be
interested
uh
his name is in the address book of
george marinshield complete with the
nickname poppy and i've also seen an
internal ca document in which george h.w
bush's director explains that he has
known george demar shield since the
early 1940s
right well obviously because of his and
because he was running the cia he wanted
to see how the cia was being uh
discussed
if i just comment on that
briefly
there's a there's actually i think a
much more important pertinent
point and that is that
according to fbi records on the
afternoon of the assassination of george
herbert walker bush phoned in a suspect
in the kennedy assassination when this
emerged
later
he couldn't remember having done it
and the cia ultimately tried to pin it
on another
george bush who
dan alcorn and i tracked down and
we got an affidavit from him
saying no that he wasn't the person
referred to in that memorandum
the actual story thank you for uh
reporting on the documents we got on the
freedom of information case in 1988
sometimes you don't think anyone pays
any attention to these cases so we
appreciate you talking about them
but the actual circumstance was that
there is an fbi document
that reflects shortly after the
assassination
that the fbi briefed mr george bush
of the cia about the reaction of the
cuban exile community
in florida to the assassination
and that's what prompted the interest in
whether
this was george bush for the 41st
president united states or not at that
point
and we filed our foia case
of course the cia generally does not
confirm or deny the identity of their
agents
in this case they did publicly release
the name
of another george bush
that worked for the cia in 1963
but they did so without contacting him
and telling him that his name was about
to be released to uh the media he was
not too happy about that
and we did we didn't actually interview
him and he said in no way
whatsoever was he the person referred to
in this fbi memo because he was a
probationary
employee at cia had only worked there a
few months they wouldn't let him even
answer the telephone because he was
essentially a messenger a paper
delivery man and he only worked at ciu
for six months and moved over to another
agency so that whole issue was left um
with exactly that fact it's reported by
the way in an article by george mcbride
in nation magazine
great okay anybody else mr talbott mrs
albert thank you for your gracious
personal reference
i have a question yes that i wrestled
with
over the years
and
had the wonderful opportunity of
speaking briefly on this with senator
richard schweiker from my state
and talking with george d martinshield
in his living room
and
talking with jim garrison
and of course all my wonderful
colleagues over the years and
testimonies three times under oath
federal judge charles halleck
rockefeller commission the house select
committee
and i've been involved in politics on
this side while i've been devoting
full-time to the jfk assassination
ignoring my wife and kids in my
profession
but i've dabbed a little bit on politics
here and there
and uh used to even be a card-carrying
member of the aclu although
i
i went with the skokie incident to push
me off the line here's a question to you
sir
given
and i'm a democrat and
past chairman of the democratic party in
my county and head of the state
committee delegation and a member of the
democratic national committee that's my
political background okay given all of
that
given the new york times and the liberal
news media and the left-wing liberal
news media in particular and their
problems and concerns and anguish going
back in world war ii incidents in korea
gate and watergate and the mili scandal
and i've discussed that too with a
professional colleague henry rothblatt
attorney rothba and all of that and up
through the years everything vincent
foster and ron brown and waco branstad
and have been involved in all those
cases too as a french pathology
consultant and all the way up to abu
ghraib tell me sir reasonable people can
disagree
on
the
pathology
the radiology
the criminalistics
the photography
the neurosurgery
despite the professor ron's dismissal
disregard disrespect and disembowelment
of all these other professions on both
sides my friend my dear friend and
colleague michael baden uh
and henry lee even people like gerald
posner and vince bullios will continue
according to professor ron to just waste
our time all of us on both sides
screwing around here with with all of
these things who gives a [ __ ] where the
holes are in or out you know what jerry
spence by the way or leftly bailly would
do to professor ron in the witness stand
you'd have to bring in kind of a special
equipment to pick up the little pieces
of the dissection and to mop up the
blood from the floor that was what
happened to him in a murder case okay
you don't have to worry about any of
that stuff just ignore it but tell me
this
how is it
that we seem to have had over the years
more concern
more puzzlement
more
more disenchantment
a greater cry for reviewing all of this
how is it that recognizing that there
are these honest differences of opinion
which reasonable people can disagree
with in all of these professions how is
it that so early on to the continuing
day
that the left-wing liberal people who
you would have thought i would have
thought would have seized upon this
seeming right-wing conspiracy whether it
did occur or not and i believe that it
did but whether it did occur that they
had no
no interest they just accepted they had
no problem at all on how these things
were handled the autopsy here the
investigation there the way in which the
warren commission treated wouldn't they
had no problem just reaching out
everything was clear well that's a good
question i get where you're going cyril
i would like okay i see where you're
headed i i think it's a good question
and it's
here's all i can tell you about that
i've wondered about it myself i come
out of a you know left media background
i was at mother jones in the 80s and now
of course i started salon and running
salon
quite clearly a liberal publication and
i've wondered often why left
intellectuals the gnome chomsky's and
and others didn't take up uh the kennedy
investigation as a cause
and ray marcus actually enlightened me
on this a bit uh you know some of you
are familiar with rey's monographs and
he's written about this
and uh when he was living in boston uh i
believe it was in the late 60s
he approached howard zinn noam chomsky
among others
there were a couple others
as well i think
and he asked them directly you know to
look into it and uh they
rebuffed him he said and my feeling is
that kennedy uh came you know was not a
hero to these people that there is in
certain left-wing circles a feeling that
the kennedys were cold warriors
that
they were trying to get rid of castro by
any means necessary that uh even to this
day you hear in right-wing circles you
know there hasn't been a a good tough uh
democratic president since john kennedy
meaning you know he was willing to kick
ass and topple governments and do
whatever was necessary for american uh
foreign interests so i think in some
left circles the kennedys are anathema
the uh you know bobby and
and jack both were were hardcore cold
warriors who didn't deserve to uh be uh
you know
supported and protected
yes in the back here
i think that's for that reason i just
said
there are reasons but
in august of 63
he signed at the cuban missile crisis
carried the hell out of everybody
including him and he signed the first
nuclear test ban treaty which i which i
think is what shouldn't be assassinated
i i have your view i have a different
view of the kennedy administration
i think the candidate administration was
at war with itself is my feeling he was
trying to end the cold war 40 years
before i think there were two strains
within the kennedy administration i
think they collided and my sense is that
in that collision you can find some
roots of this assassination i think
there were two uh as i say uh
you know two tracks on cuba clearly we
know that there was a back channel using
uh bill atwood the diplomat the u.n
former journalist uh to pursue peace uh
with castro at the same time where there
was a still an aggressive strategy to
topple his government
and i think certain people in the hard
line felt that the kennedys had betrayed
them and that's certainly
been documented i think very well
right here
the false linking of oswald to the fair
play cuba for cuba committee
and the um
apparent left-wing credentials of lee
harvey oswald the pro-castro credentials
and the fact that the left-wing media
may have been a very they closed down
the fair play for cuba committee the
assassination did and maybe the nation
and some of the left-wing media felt so
grateful for having been led off the
hook remember we're coming right out of
the mccarthy era
it looked like mccarthy girl was
daunting then when they confined
everything to the
uh
strange precinct of oswald psyche the
left-wing media may have he decided
relief
is that possible
you know that's getting into an area
that i'm afraid i don't have uh much
expertise on i think though it's a
fascinating subject what the left-wing
media did on the investigation on the
assassination in the 60s have to look at
warren hinkle and ramparts in some ways
was the you know one of my early
inspirations uh as a california
journalist and i think uh warren hinkle
with bill turner did some interesting
work on the uh assassination so i don't
think all the left-wing media decided
that the you know screw the kennedys who
cares if they were killed but i think
that was the only attitude in some
doctrinaire left circles
on your left surface is the issue of jfk
vietnam uh there were
exchanges in uh two articles originally
wrote
serious
published by alex coburn in the nation
and after alex coburn gave up the issue
of jfk in vietnam max holland here took
it up arguing that it was a fantasy that
jack kennedy was not going to have
americanized the war well now we have
david kaiser who's sitting in the
audience here who has spent many many
long
years in the in the files and howard
jones who published oxford university
press uh published book called the death
of a generation in which
i won't paraphrase uh david kaiser but i
will paraphrase david
jones because he's not here and he can't
blame me when i get it wrong but he says
that when he first heard the idea that
kennedy wasn't going to americanize the
war uh he thought that was a silly idea
uh and essentially the reason he
apparently wrote this book or a strong
motivation for it was that when he
actually looked at the files the
evidence that kennedy was not going to
americanize the war was so overwhelming
that he had to write the book to
basically
atone for his
serious misperception you will not hear
that in the nation you'll never hear a
correction of of that in the nation and
uh and nor will you hear that generally
in left-wing circles despite the fact
that i think that it's overwhelmingly
now the view of most people who know
this information that jack kennedy was
clear yeah well you will in salon i
think uh the work my my own work sid
blumenthal's work uh jamie galbraith
others have i think a more benign uh a
view of the kennedy administration and
think that it was uh grappling its way
towards i think uh a rethinking of the
cold war
before it was terminated but i do think
there was definitely conflicting forces
within the kennedy administration
hardline force and a more
uh progressive force uh symbolized by
theodore sorens and uh among others ted
sorensen who wrote the american
university speech
and i think jim's getting the hook
yeah we're
we have a short break scheduled and then
we're going to have an absolutely
fasting fascinating program the rest of
the afternoon uh which hopefully will
match what david talbot has done and i
think it i think it will thank you david
one quick announcement
[Applause]
the following speakers
[Music]
um and also just to remind you that our
times are open until 7 today
here's what's ahead on c-span
next a look at the warren report and